there are heritable characteristics in
psychopaths psychopaths don't really
seem to feel any remorse to what they do
they struggle to have empathy with other
people and they can be very callous they
can do things and not really feel sorry
for them they don't have the connection
between the prefrontal cortex of the
brain and the amygdala the rest of us do
to identify things like disgust fear
anger psychopaths don't really interpret
those signals in the same way
mark friedstein welcome to the show
thanks chris pleasure to be here
for those people that are watching on
youtube you may notice a slight change
in my usual recording setup i'm still
here in guatemala it's taking a little
bit longer than expected to get my visa
back from the u.s embassy so this is the
hotel room locale
and i've brought a coconut from
downstairs at the breakfast buffet so
all is not completely terrible but today
speaking about psychopaths
why is it that you got into working with
psychopaths mark i don't know what
compels someone to think
when they're in their youth that this is
the road that they want to travel down
well that's a really good question chris
i think lots of people do want to be
forensic psychologists i think you know
good crime scene and csi and all that
stuff has got the word forensic into
people's brains is something glamorous
maybe and there's never a sort of
shortage of people with an interest in
serial killers quite a few of whom
tend to be psychopaths although by not
all means all but i i didn't i kind of
didn't really have any of that i just
sort of fell into it my
my job was as a sociologist i was a
sociology phd student and the way that i
um practiced was
using a technique called ethnography
where you basically put yourself in with
a group of people doing something you
think is cool and interesting you watch
them do it you do a little bit yourself
maybe participant observation and then
you write about it and my phd was on
anti-globalization protest which is
miles away but just as i was finishing
the local mental health trust opened a
new wing in brampton hospital which is
one of the three maximum security mental
hospitals in the uk
four people that were called dangerous
and severe personality disorder so that
means basically people who are
psychopaths or people who have very very
complex and and usually uh high risk
personality disorders such as antisocial
or borderline personalities or that
means that they're at risk of committing
a crime and and the opportunity came out
to do an ethnography there i was like
yeah that sounds great cool sign me up
what's a psychopath
and i just sort of i just sort of stuck
there so i really did honestly fall into
it um i think early on in my career i
was a little bit kind of running from
pillar to post being manipulated
confused and not generally getting the
whole thing but with time you know it
sort of comes i guess was there a harsh
learning lesson early on in your career
did you
uh with wet behind the ears and naive
was there anything that you came up
against
i definitely definitely i think two
two classic ones is first of all um
psychopaths are very manipulative you
know so when you meet a psychopath for a
short space of time you are often
experienced what we call the glib and
superficial charm so i often say someone
if you had to have a 10 minute
conversation with the psychopath you
probably wouldn't notice anything
untoward you might actually find it
quite warm and
you know pleasant and certainly charming
because that's part of the disorder i
think it comes from the way that
psychopaths learn about other people by
observing what other people respond well
to but without having that sort of sense
of wanting to please others but simply
aping the behavior that they see around
them so when i was working in the prison
service
there was a very very charming and very
very manipulative psychopath and i think
i wasn't the only person to be deceived
by this man but he was also playing in
the guitar club where i i played the
bass guitar myself so i'd come to the
guitar club and provide a bit of bass
backing for all the prisoners doing
leonard cohen and white stripe songs and
we'd meet there and we'd talk about
music and things and um
i was uh
sort of i found this guy very
intimidating would call him paul for the
sake of argument it's also known in my
book but he
i found it quite intimidating at first
but over time we kind of got to know
each other and we bonded a little bit
over music and he asked me sort of
towards the end of my time at the prison
uh whether i bring him in some um sheet
music on the internet
now you think about something like this
and you're like well you know what's the
harm right it's a few pages printed off
of you know guitar tablature or
something what could possibly be done
with it
yeah give someone a nasty paper cut i
mean
it's not worth the time and spending
segregation for that i don't think so i
thought well let's you know that's fine
let's go ahead and do it but of course
what manipulation like that
doesn't sort of come it doesn't start
with somebody asking you to bring in you
know half a kilogram of cocaine into the
prison right it starts with little
things like that so as it turned out i i
brought the um the sheet music to the
prison and left it in my car because i
had other things on my mind i think i
also had this sort of twinge of
conscience at the last minute like maybe
this isn't such a good idea and then i
had to spend some time away from the
prison when i came back it turned out
that not only had paul been manipulating
several other members of staff in many
ways but he was actually having a sexual
relationship with one of the female
officers um and it had all come out and
i think you know
this sort of thing happens from time to
time but the problem was that it was
quite clear that other officers were
aware that this was going on but hadn't
said anything and when you have that
kind of collusion where everyone's
supporting
the manipulation to take place
it really is quite worrying because it
means the person at the center the
psychopath in this case has fingers in
virtually all parts of the organization
everything is very compromised so once
you have that happen paul has to be
trans had to be transferred out and the
prison officer lost her job and was
quite lucky she wasn't in mental health
because otherwise she would have
been possibly accused and convicted of
sexual abuse so that
that's one aspect because manipulation
is constantly you know right there when
you work with psychopaths the second
thing is that not everybody who's a
psychopath is necessarily rock hard
scary and manipulative some of them are
really really quite vulnerable and you
you often find yourself getting into the
state feeling sorry for them or feeling
what we'd call a sort of heart sink
where you look oh my god this guy's had
such a terrible life and it's usually
with the younger men i'm a dad now and i
think i may have had a bit of a dad-like
impulse at the time that oh look at this
guy he's had a terrible life and all his
you know all his rage is directed
inwards but the thing is that
even when people are not outwardly
aggressive and difficult like paul but
maybe like someone like danny in my book
where he just constantly harming himself
and can't really see
the good in himself the problem is that
is that can actually be quite bottomless
that lack of self-esteem that lack of an
identity and if you start pouring
empathy into it which i did initially
and a lot of staff i think never
actually stop it just keeps being
drained from me you never reach a point
where that person has
filled up with the empathy and the love
that they need because they haven't been
able to change the way they think about
other people fundamentally so those two
things sort of
you know riding the line between
being
alert to the fact you're being
manipulated but also trying to give an
appropriate amount of empathy and
sympathy that's what makes the job
really really really really challenging
and i think part of the reason that we
were never able to fill the the nursing
and the doctor and the psychology post
that we wanted to to make the program a
success but there you have it um are
there different types of psychopaths
another in narcissism you have grandiose
narcissists and
vulnerable narcissists that's right is
there any sort of equivalent in
psychopathy
i'm very glad you asked me that question
chris because this is my this is my
current um thinking about it because i
think
if you
if you look at paul and danny so we have
somebody who's uh you know history as a
sort of drug enforcer he killed a man
but he didn't do it directly he got
other people to do it for him and then
denied all
plausibly denied the manipulating guy
that's right oh yeah as his as is his
character evidently
absolutely killed him with some guitar
sheet music
or got someone else to kill her with
and then
you take someone like danny who has a
much more sort of
um personal crime where he is
he forms a sort of a healthy
relationship with the local priest and
then
when he thinks that the priest is
rejecting him for his ideas he stabs him
in the back um it doesn't kill him but
you know it's a really horrible thing to
do to somebody who's trying to help you
um
when you think that both of those two
men would have met the criteria for
being a psychopath
there's lots of argument about where the
threshold is using the psychopathy
checklist which we can maybe go into
later but these guys were both way up
there like way over the american
threshold of 30 which is higher than the
british one
and to say that those guys are both
defined by being psychopaths is i think
totally unhelpful on a number of levels
and this this debate actually goes back
a long way to the 1940s and 50s when
herv collectly first published his book
on the mask of sanity how to identify a
psychopath and he uh
quickly there was a debate in american
psychiatry about the fact that actually
there were two kinds of psychopaths
there were people that we would
call a psychopath or understand a
psychopath to be who always have this
sort of um it feels like a
characterological element and when i say
that i mean that they were sort of born
that way
and when you read books like we need to
talk about kevin uh by lionel shriver or
you see people who are just bad to the
bone on tv like um
patrick bateman or hannibal lecter those
are what was traditionally thought of as
being a psychopath and there was another
term sociopath which referred to people
who presented in much the same way as a
psychopath so they had that same lack of
empathy they tended to lie but they were
a bit more violent they were a bit more
sort of uncontrolled they're a bit more
sort of impulsive and they were termed
sociopaths now we don't really use those
words anymore but the idea of a sort of
primary psychopath
and the secondary psychopath the primary
psychopath being much more narcissistic
and much more sort of uh outward
directed and the second
secondary psychopath being a little bit
more inward directed and maybe
being a psychopath simply for them is a
way of defending against horrible
emotions and feelings and guilt and
shame for the things they may or may not
have done as kids
so that that distinction has always been
there and i think if you get really into
it you can see how some narcissistic
psychopaths and primary psychopaths
might be
more or less charming and they might be
people who are simply you know very very
good to talk to and great con men
whereas others
i think this is especially true of
robbers just tend to have this really
macho image where they think they're on
top of the world and they don't need to
be charming because if people don't like
them let's bully them into into into
being friends you know so there are many
more gradations we can start to make
is the psychopath sociopath
distinction is that even a thing
is that just bro science or is is that
used as a terminology
its sociopath was used um but then when
the americans published their dsm-4 the
way that they diagnosed mental disorder
they included in 1983 they included
something called antisocial personality
disorder and this is pretty much um
it's just a term for the sort of the
behavioral aspect of psychopathy so none
of the sort of calming manipulative
charming stuff but more the sort of
antisocial lifestyle parasitism telling
lies lacking remorse
breaking the law things like that and
that came to be known as sociopathy over
time but and i think because of that
confusion between you know a proper
psychopath who's probably made more by
the environment than by their genes
being a sociopath to somebody simply
with antisocial personality disorder and
to get the antisocial personalization is
a much more inclusive term i think
something like 80 percent of people in
prison in the uk and something like 70
of those in the usa will have this
diagnosis because one of the traits is
breaking the law so you break the law a
lot
check
but then you get around to this well why
did they break the law because they've
got on the social personality disorder
why they got and social personalities
because they broke the law it doesn't
really go anywhere so it's not a
terribly helpful diagnosis but if you
think of it as a sort of a venn diagram
the vast majority of psychopaths will
also have antisocial personality
disorder um
and and
most people who have antisocial
personality won't be psychopaths and
there's only that sort of interesting
distinction of
people with a diagnosis of psychopathy
who won't have aspd and then more we
like to think of a successful psychopath
people who haven't been caught or people
who just don't break the law but they're
still psychopaths right
how much is heritability and genetics
uh how much does that play a role when
it comes to someone becoming a
psychopath and how much of it is the
environment
so that's a tricky one because we have
pretty good evidence that there are
i suppose
heritable characteristics in psychopaths
and in particular those are what we call
the callus on emotional traits so the
fact that psychopaths don't really seem
to feel any remorse so what they do they
struggle to have empathy with other
people and they can be very callous they
can do things and not really feel sorry
for them i think because you know their
wiring is different they don't have the
connection between
uh the
forefront of the prefrontal cortex of
the brain and the amygdala the rest of
us do to identify things like you know
um
disgust fear anger disappointment that
we sort of live our lives by psychopaths
don't really interpret those signals in
the same way so they don't feel shame
they don't feel guilt and children as
young as seven or nine years old can
experience or show those traits as well
but of course a large proportion of them
won't then go on to be psychopaths i
think only about 40 percent will ever
progress to a point where they have
something like you know enough enough
traits to be diagnosable as a psychopath
so it's not the whole picture to say
it's just it's just genes and then
there's you know these wonderful cases
like james fallon and impressive
neuroscience in stanford university uh
successful career i'm very interested in
psychopathy himself i wonder why and he
was doing a study where he exposes
people to um
unpleasant stimuli like looking at a an
unpleasant image of maybe wound detail
or maybe a pleasant image of a butterfly
or something like that and then he
measures their their brain response
using um i think is contrast tomography
so you look at which areas of the brain
are being activated like a ct scan um
and then you you look at particular
areas of the brain corresponding to how
people are with the stimulus that people
are receiving so if you give a
psychopath an image of um
i'd know a war zone and you gave the
same image to someone who isn't a
psychopath the psychopath will show much
lower levels of neurological activity in
response to that stimulus because they
don't recognize that something is
necessarily bad
so jim is conducting this experiment and
he has a lot of clinical psychopaths for
his experimental arm and he's looking
for some people for his control arm and
he's struggling because he's used up all
his grad students and he hasn't properly
advertised he was like well i'll just
scan myself and then you know that'll be
fine and then he's looking through the
results of the trial and he finds in his
control arm
a brain scan for someone who really
looks very very psychopathic there's
virtually no brain activation he's
written a book about this uh which is
really interesting and the the scans in
the book and it's terrifying this person
is completely psychopathic oh my god
have i got this wrong is this person
definitely in the control group and he
looks at the scan goes to his master key
where we see all the people who are
taking part and he realizes that this is
his own brain scan he is functionally a
psychopath uh studying psychopaths at
stanford university he's got a wife and
kid he's got a very successful career
and he thinks about it and he thinks
well
actually when i really think about it
i really i struggle with a lot of the
roles that i play in life because i
don't see why i have to don't see why i
have to be a good dad when people come
to stay at my house i just think why why
am i letting you eat my food it's my
food get out of here i didn't invite you
who are you anyway
and these kids are uh there's also a
little video associated to promote the
book and his kid's like yeah that can be
difficult
he doesn't really do emotion things like
all these little tiny clues that add up
to a picture of somebody who you know
clearly has some sort of background
maybe
you know a relative or something that
would have caused this psychopath to
come back but doesn't have any of the
behavioral features you know good career
good family life a bit cranky at the
weekends maybe but that could describe
me as well i'm far too neurotic to be a
psychopath would he have met the
criteria whatever is 26 or above or 30
or above on the scale would you have met
that
no he wouldn't he wouldn't because i
think that the psychopath test bob has
psychology checklist revised uh has
pretty much
and it's like saying equal split but
actually the behavioral stuff so
breaking the law being impulsive being
irresponsible taking drugs uh
being what we call criminally versatile
so having a lot of offences from
different categories all that's in the
secondary cycle factor factor two as we
call it and jim fallon had none of that
so he'd never even got halfway up the
scale which wouldn't have had anything
enough to diagnose him as a clinical
psychopath if you like well that's
interesting because what that shows is
that you can have someone who um has the
predisposition or perhaps the
ingredients uh to become a psychopath
but for whichever reason they haven't um
behaviorally deployed that into the
world in a psychopathic way is that the
right way to look at it
absolutely and i i think i could i can i
can even support your hypothesis a bit
further by saying that all of the
psychopaths i've met in you know in
clinical practice have lives that are
really just messed up and i can mean a
lot of different things like that like
some of them are from the middle class
but their relationships with their
parents their mothers and fathers are
messed up and really sort of sometimes
quite twisted ways and you know the
example of this is something we call
enmeshment where
somebody never quite breaks away from
one of their parents so
typically or let's talk about um
tony who's one of the cases in my book
he had an immense relationship with his
mother where he was never really able to
break away from her emotionally so even
though he was in his late 40s when i was
working with him and his mother would
come to visit often they would part with
quite a lingering kiss on the lips and i
used to get all of these um
you know just very upset nurses who've
been supervising the visit saying oh
they did that thing again you know
we have to address this and sort of you
know visits in hospitals are quite
sacred so we we can't invest in it but
it really did freak people out and and
the way that uh
you know he seemed to sort of function
or do the things he did just to sort of
please his mother all the time
was really interesting in the way that
it sort of overrid his his own
personality it sort of it meant that he
his own personality you know who who are
you
tony and he would really struggle to
answer that question as well he was a
very good con man he was very
psychopathic but none of those things
really make a person
who they are and i think one of the
reasons that he was such a good comment
is because he could play any role
because he wasn't really playing a role
that was him he lacked a sort of you
know i'm mark i'm an academic i'm
neurotic i do very strange things in my
spare time like read about so i'm
reading write about psychopaths that's
who i am but for tony there wasn't that
sort of core he didn't have anything
that wasn't the slick con man yeah
there's no
concrete sense of self is there is very
very malleable if you were to
if you were to design the childhood
to activate
the uh psychopathic genetic tendency
what would you what would you have
happened to a child
it's an interesting way round of asking
it chris but i'd say you've got you've
got a lot of options unfortunately
you've got um so we let's start thinking
about someone like tony where does
enmeshment come from and i think
enmeshment comes from well in tony's
case there's two things first of all a
father who's very um
very
sort of very potent very present so the
father was a con man as well a very
successful one considerably more
successful than tony because i can't
find any record of who he was remember
being caught but there we go um uh and
and then uh the father in turn's case
disappeared so once
if her father leaves a kid
particularly in sort of you know the
pre-teen teen years
they can become very very um
i guess uh
embedded in the kids memories as like a
perfect dad yeah they they didn't stay
around enough to [ __ ] it up basically so
in that case the relationship turns very
much towards the mother because that's
the only parent you've got left and in
this specific case i think the mother
also um tended to be very very
overbearing she didn't want to separate
from her son she wanted him to be around
all the time she wanted to have
almost like an adult intimate
relationship with them you know with not
necessarily sexual but having that sort
of you know that that same level of
intimacy like we cannot part we cannot
be different from each other and if you
look back at some of the early
psychoanalytic writing from the 40s 50s
and 60s this is all very much identified
very strong patriarchal figure um and
potentially overbearing over enmeshed
mother as well
lots of people talk about ted bundy as
being the sort of literally about to say
the same thing because his mother was
still at the trial
that had this sort of angel boy my my
beautiful perfect child's vision of him
right and and that and okay so there's
that and there's also the fact that you
know i think his father was not
particularly somebody but his
grandfather was a hugely sort of
paternalistic overbearing dominating
figure in his life and uh he there were
all these sort of signs that would
encourage somebody to to be psychopathic
i don't know about this is the
interesting thing is being a psychopath
doesn't necessarily make you a criminal
like jim fallon right you what pushed
bundy bundy to commit his crime
specifically is a different question but
certainly being a psychopath and not
having that same level of moral
restraint could make it easier for you
to commit crimes like that the other if
we think a little bit about what we talk
about sociopathy as well on secondary
psychopaths i think they can be much
more formed by an environment this is
very abusive and harsh and i remember
somebody i worked with in the uk
actually who was very much
you know a sociopath a secondary
psychopath so somebody who wasn't
charming wasn't particularly cunning
wasn't very glib but was very
anti-social
a very remorseless
and very callous you know did bad things
a lot of people didn't feel bad about it
he he recounted this this episode that
still stays with me he's not in the book
he's just a very interesting character
and and he was 12 years old and he was
um
his dad was very again very dominant but
he and his dad wanted him to be tough
you know so he gets into a fight with
some older boys and this guy was you
know even in his 40s very cheeky and
sort of like to push boundaries so he
probably said something a little bit out
of his station so much group much bolder
boys chase him alone down the street and
he knows he's going to get everything
beaten out of him if he stays around so
he runs home bangs on the door
his dad opens the door and says what is
it
uh jim and jim says oh these these guys
are chasing me they're going to beat me
up dad you've got to help me and he says
no sort it out yourself it'll make you
strong closes the door in his face other
guys arrived beat him at right side
right outside his family's front door
and he never forgets that but he doesn't
remember it as i would which is my god
wasn't your dad an awful bastard
but rather as his dad making him tough
and this being a good thing that you
know his dad made him realize that at
the end nobody's got your background
that's an awful lesson to learn from
that story but nevertheless
if you are brought up like that then
you're gonna develop something like a
psychopathic defense because feeling
emotion and trying to think about events
like that in terms of what they mean for
you as a person it's gonna be really
hard so better just not to think about
them emotionally at all better distance
yourself and act like a psychopath
have you got any idea why psychopathy is
adaptive why it would have evolved at
all
so
we often think about this about
personality disorders of all kinds
because they they're chronic they don't
go away um
i think the way that we think about
personalities or in terms of anti-social
narcissistic borderline hysteronic isn't
terribly helpful because it suggests
that there's sort of a typical
psychopath or a typical narcissist or a
typical
schizoid person and that is very rarely
the case these people are often very
very different but they do have these
sort of core features
and i think the thinking is if if
particularly you
uh if we think back to um
let's say vikings yeah a society with
very very limited resources it has to
sort of parasitize from other societies
in order to gain the resources it needs
to proliferate right to start new
colonies to expand so
uh you know we both lived in uh
newcastle for a while and lindisfarne
the monastery there was very rich and
very prone to raiding invaded
and they they were sacked and they were
murdered and then all that stuff was
taken they kept coming back bless them
and i think you know there's some sort
of period when the 16th century where
the vikings came four or five times a
year
in order to do that to be able to i mean
you know anybody can do something
terrible but to be able to do something
terrible and then do it again and i
think this is where we start thinking
about post-traumatic stress disorder
it's literally the case that some
offenders in prison have done such
terrible things that they've traumatized
themselves so when they sort of say i
don't really remember the offense in
some cases they might be telling the
truth because they they may not be
actually able to access those memories
but that isn't how a psychopath works
because a psychopath won't experience
that shame and trauma in response to
doing bad things because they don't see
these as bad things they see i'm going
to go and protect my family in order to
protect my family i have to provide them
with food and i have to provide them
with clothes i have to provide them with
wealth so that we can have more kids if
i have to kill some people to do that
it's not a problem because that's what i
want to do and this is what we call
instrumental reasoning so all that the
focus is is on the end yeah the means
are totally relevant yeah i need to get
there if people die or get messed up on
the way
oh well that's unfortunate because you
say it's unfortunate but i don't really
buy into that so having a group of
people in your society not all of them i
should stress but a group of people in
your society who can repeatedly go out
and do
violent stressful traumatic things in
service of the wider family is extremely
adaptive and you can actually think of
how there are certain models like this
for things like borderline personality
disorder people who lack a fixed
identity who require a level of support
and steer that just isn't available in
our societies anymore today you can see
how genetically that would actually be
quite adaptive but in modern societies
where you can't be a violent [ __ ] and
you can't be entirely dependent on other
people for everything you want because
it's an individualistic society they're
no longer adaptive and they cause
problems with people and they also cause
problems with people around them as well
dude you blow my mind that's so
interesting that's so interesting
so
if you were to think of a typical tribe
you're done by a hundred person tribe or
whatever as
like a football team you need a
goalkeeper and your goalkeeper has a
very specific role to play now it
wouldn't the team wouldn't work if
everybody tried to be a goalkeeper
now the same thing is happening here so
i had um
i had a really good discussion about
narcissists a couple of years ago
and in that
it was basically suggested that
the um
social ecology constrains narcissism
that if you have too many narcissists it
becomes so chaotic within your tribe
that it can't continue to to work so not
only do you have social norms which
restricts sort of narcissistic
tendencies but narcissists are probably
killed at a higher rate than
non-narcissist people and i'm gonna
guess that psychopaths it's like a
high-risk high-reward strategy of
existing so
you're more likely to die but you're
also more likely to become the
billionaire or the chieftain of the
tribe or something like that which is a
lot of the time why people point the
finger at presidents and say that
they're a psychopath so
but that's so interesting to think that
individually as a person
psychopathy whether it's adaptive or not
is kind of up for debate but for the
tribe overall having a few psychopaths
or maybe one or two psychopaths per
group is actually like having a very
specialized weapon or a tool that you
can deploy into certain certain
circumstances and then if you scale up
to the size of you know the vikings i
don't know how big that was but i'm
going to guess perhaps in the thousands
you may be able to condense down
a
boat a long boat of 30 psychopaths with
a couple of non-psychopaths and you can
send them over to lindisfarne to sack
them and and come back that's so good
yeah and i think just to add to that
the other thing about psychopaths is
they have terrible risk reward reasoning
particularly socially so if you
you know if you play a game of poker
with a psychopath they'll continue to
bet outrageously
um based on very very bad cards and i
think that that's really interesting
that psychopaths are such good con men
in some cases you know they can actually
carry that off they can play brag very
effectively um but if you have somebody
who can't make those risk rule
calculators think if i go off to
lindisfarne they may have got wise and
stationed you know celtic soldiers all
the way around the edges and we're going
to go there and we're going to get
[ __ ] up they won't think of it in that
kind of way all they'll be focused on is
the potential reward the risk is
irrelevant to psychologists we've shown
this again again in research literature
that they just don't you know they don't
factor that in and also if you you know
again i was talking about trauma
psychopaths come back from these raids
and they're not traumatized they can
just go and do it again and again until
they're all killed off and i think with
the example you were using of
narcissists
again there is sort of like you know a
sense of maybe a critical mass or maybe
a point to which um those kind of traits
are valued by our society but only up to
a point
you you know you you can only be in as
much so much of an artist before it
becomes intolerable for society and i
think that changes over time i think the
amount of nurses that will accept shifts
quite a lot um i'm not necessarily in
so i think about autism as a clinical
condition and when i read stuff from the
united states about there being an
epidemic of narcissism i've recently
written an article that got quite a lot
of attention that says that's not how
it's not helpful i think someone's like
selfies and post them on instagram we're
not we're not talking about that
no we're good because we need to draw a
line between i think we all have we all
need a bit of what's called narcissistic
supply we all need a little bit of uh
telling that we're good right done right
things yeah that we're important right
and if we don't have that then our
self-esteem drops and we feel terrible
um and and narcissists particularly
grandiose narcissists don't have that
need at all because they're so
absolutely convinced that they're
they're right that it's uh you know it's
sort of a non-issue so like with
psychopathy and narcissism together and
there's a lot of correlation between the
two i should say so rather sort of more
grandiose narcissists can also have
psychopathy and vice versa um i think
there is a limit and i think that if we
think about stephen pinker's work on the
reduction of violence in societies over
time
these aren't societies that value the
traits and the qualities that
psychopaths have but i'm sure that there
were such societies at many stages in
our past who was that guy that tried to
get someone to buy the eiffel tower
i do know your french comments some time
ago i do know who you mean but but that
that so someone like tony um that's an
old con you know selling off uh
old um
uh ones of the world or structures that
have you know had quite a few years on
them and plausibly could be ready to be
decommissioned and replaced at something
better that's one of the oldest cons in
the book is you try and attract
investors into this great opportunity
and you're basically selling you know
selling the eiffel tower to someone
who's gullible enough to believe that it
could be up for sale and that's all
about that's all about the graft right
that's all about how you present
yourself as a plausible salesman so
someone like tony in the book you know
he's he's got the best suits he's got
his own bank he's got a chauffeur he's
got a mercedes stretch mercedes benz all
things that he's obtained through very
dodgy means but nevertheless you know
when you start signing checks from your
own bank people start to pay attention
and if you've seen enough and i think
with tony's case he'd seen enough from
his dad about how you get people to buy
a cotton it's very difficult
because
this is what um i don't want to get too
technical we call this malignant
pseudo-identification so you see what
somebody wants in a situation you learn
from watching other people in the same
situation fall for the con and you think
why do they fall for the con and you're
not thinking emotionally you're thinking
they fall for the con because they want
this so if i can promise that
plausibly then i can pretty much take
them for everything they've got because
once i have them
believing they're going to get you know
a 10 000 return on their scrap of the
eiffel tower
then but you know they're finished
because the psychopath will keep doing
that that scam over and again i work
with a a guy who poses a police officer
and he would go into people's uh flats
and offer to move their jewelry and
money to a safe place in the flat um i'd
say it was you know obviously a secret
police procedure and he'd tell them
where he's going to leave it he'd take
it put it all in a police marked bag and
then walk out of the house and then tell
them to check after he's gone it was all
there but of course when they checked it
wasn't there and he wasn't police
officers there was no way they'd track
it down and that you know isn't a
particularly complex scam but what is
amazing is the fact that he had
something like 600 instances of the same
scam on his rap sheet like 600 it's just
unbelievable numbers of
sort of cons that have gone down in this
kind how good he must have been to be
able to identify people who would fall
for this and carry it out again and
again and again so it really is quite a
sort of remorseless
rate of success once they get the graft
right you know
what's interesting to me is that
psychopathy
perhaps for a long time throughout human
history let's say maybe the last 10 000
20 000 years
has been pretty useful
and then for the last
100 200 300 years
it's now no longer adaptive it's now a
big problem and um
it's kind of strange that we may have
like
culturally competed psychopaths out of
their place in society
well i wouldn't go too too hard with
that i mean i think there's still a lot
of places where psychopaths can flourish
to a degree i think the difficulty is
that
we have to think
a little bit more carefully in the way
we define psychology particularly about
whether things like aggression violence
and anti-social behavior are necessarily
part of that and if you think about i
don't know i'm sure we can all imagine
some recent political figures who've
been diagnosed with psychopaths are they
aggressive are they anti-social i mean
they're very self-serving i'm sure but
those those
descriptors don't really define them so
we need to think more crisply i think
about what it is that makes a psychopath
we need to do that without thinking
about behavior because the factors that
drive behavior are very very complicated
i was a a colleague of mine kerry danes
forensic psychologist has also written
books about her work and she says i know
a guy who is
a murderer they've killed i think about
15 people in their life's life's
lifetime they've uh
killed women and children included in
that total but they've never been to
prison and they're not a psychopath and
this person is of course a uh an sas
commando special forces commander who
does this as part of their job
now that behavior
it's possible this person is a
psychopath sure you know my colleague
didn't think so and she's quite
experienced so it's possible this person
is a a psychopath but
that's sort of irrelevant here because
the reason that they're doing these
things is not because they are
instrumentally driven it's because it's
their job and it's their function in
life to do that so we can't really infer
psychopathy from behavior and we need to
start moving away from that way of
defining cycle think much more in terms
of the sort of psychological emotional
traits that people have and if we were
able to do that well i guess the core is
that we have a lot more identify a lot
more psychopaths in
probably politics used car sales
possibly
chief executives is it true stop traders
does that um
that sort of focal thing about one
percent of this the population of
psychopaths is that is there any legs to
that
yeah it's less than that but um we did
uh in the 2000 adult psychiatric
mobility survey which is a
representative survey of um people in
the uk uh which there isn't currently an
equivalent of in the usa but there are
some other servers you can use to
estimate it um
we actually included the ptlsv the
screening version of the psychopathy
checklist which you don't need to do a
long interview for
and we looked at the proportion of
people who were diagnosable psychopaths
in the uk household populations about 1
or 0.4 to 0.6 percent so about 1 in 170
200 people would have been diagnosable
as a psychopath um
which is still quite hard that i would
have
yeah yeah and if you think you know they
tend to get banged up with quite a high
propensity we did also find that group
the group of successful psychopaths who
didn't have long criminal careers but
what was interesting about was that they
did use a lot of designer drugs they
tended to have quite high risk
high-reward jobs they also had declared
bankruptcy a lot more often
and very interestingly their annual
average household income was
significantly higher than people in uh
the general population so they were
successful like more successful than not
just getting by but actually flourishing
give or take the odd bankruptcy high
risk high reward man high risk
why is it why is it that there's so few
female psychopaths
well i think that that sort of that part
of this is recursive like if we
are judging psychopathy
on the basis of behavior
um male men are more antisocial they
have more there are more antisocial men
and women who go to prison than men who
meet the criteria for juvenile
delinquency for criminal versatility for
poor behavioral controls and therefore
there's sort of a bias factor in using
something like the psychopathy checklist
because
we use a lot of behavior that's just
more typically associated with men
there are female psychopaths in my book
i talk about angela simpson
who presents you know very much as a
really seriously high scoring male
psychopath very what does that mean
so that means that on the psychopathy
checklist she would score in the mid to
high 30s you know that very few of the
items that she doesn't doesn't doesn't
hit
very glib very superficially charming
very manipulative because she
manipulates a disabled man into her
apartment on the premise of sex and then
tortures and brutally murders him over a
long long period of time so it's a
really gratuitous and pleasant offense
and i think actually
when
phoebe wallabridge was starting to think
about killing eve she wanted to start
thinking about psychopaths she saw these
interviews on tv and she was like that's
amazing and they are real that's really
really masculine presenting psychopath
traits and that there's a sort of
it's a literature that sort of how
people think about female psychopaths
that there isn't really
there isn't really a sort of clinical
basis for like we don't have a lot of
female psychopaths so we're kind of
guessing here but people think of female
psychopaths as more emotionally
aggressive using people as cat sports
something of something like um dangerous
liaisons uh where you know the marquez
uses people around her to do the dirty
work so she can manipulate people but
that can do it behind the scenes um
that's sort of the archetype but again
if you were doing that successfully you
wouldn't necessarily get caught for it
and and secondly
of the the 2000 we commissioned like
2000 beds for may male psychopaths in
the uk dangerous and severe personality
disorder and then
44 t-beds four zero beds for women of
which 15 were only ever filled and a lot
of the rest were just decommissioned so
the profile of women who we would be
able to use to say a research population
as females like was very very small and
we don't know enough to sort of say well
the archetypal female psychopath is like
this the evidence that we do have is
that psychopathy tends to be invariant
but then you can't have
behavioral invariance and one of the
behavioral factors is aggression or
anti-sociality for example because we
know those biases men i suppose as well
that if you have
aggression and beating someone up or
killing somebody is such a obvious
red flag
for you to identify a psychopath whereas
i it must be easier to get away with
manipulating people doing the catapult
type thing you know the femme fatale
type but without perhaps the physical
aggression because fewer people are
going to report the fact that they were
conned by a woman and blah blah blah
blah so yeah that's i mean what you're
saying is if you are going to be a
psychopath make sure that you're a woman
first because it's going to be easier
on average to get away with it uh but
what explain the story of that lady
because that was really that was really
surprising what she did to that man
well
this is a
this is a again a very psychopathic
trait of um a sort of grandiosity so
believing that you are the the you know
the center of the world your decisions
are the right ones to always make and
she
uh she worked as a sex worker and a
waitress and she had um she knew a guy
in the community around her who'd been
to prison for a while and um they they
had a sort of on-off relationship thing
and he was you know he probably
destroyed his body with drugs and
alcohol other things and he was
sometimes used a wheelchair to get
around
and then one day it turned out she heard
i think from a third party that this guy
said um that he'd informed on one of his
uh colleagues uh for criminal behavior
to the police
and she sort of from this you know idle
conversation forms an idea she's gonna
kill him so she persuades him to come
and meet her and then she's sort of you
know quite tantalizing and and sort of
sexually provocative uh and gets him to
come back to her flat and leaves his
wheelchair at quite some distance in the
stairway it doesn't look like away from
the stereo so it doesn't look like he's
come in there and then you know brings
him into the the living room sits him
down from the tv then ties him up while
he's not got his wheelchair can't really
get away and start torturing him driving
nails into his skull and he he lives for
about sort of seven or eight hours
through this and only dies in the early
morning after the end of the ordeal and
then she
gets her current partner to help her
take the body that says dismember it
burn it and get rid of the evidence um
all because she doesn't like she says
she doesn't like snitches and if you
there's a lot of youtube videos
available of her being interviewed by
some of the american tv channels and
it's quite chilling the way that she
presents this you know somebody says
would you do it again as hell yeah
without a second's hesitation you know
really
actually just aggressive it's just
aggressive the way that she presents a
very very
remorseless careless um
just
you know pretty typical male psychopathy
um and that's quite rare
in a
female presenting or sorry a female
president with psychopathy but there are
elements to it that fit with the
stereotypes like she you know she
doesn't just dispose of the body on her
own she gets her boyfriend to do it and
gets him to keep stunned with
some sort of promise you know there's
the sort of sense of
you know she's using sexuality
to bring somebody up to be uh to be
murdered maybe
uh some i'd well i can't think of any of
the uh the male cycles i've worked with
is doing that although some of them
would um attack sex workers
so it's not who was that one in america
was it the night stalker was he the one
that was going around killing
the endless numbers of
oh no there was the the yorkshire ripper
in the uk
was someone that was almost exclusively
working on uh sex workers right
yes yes yes that that's right and there
was a um
uh i worked with a uh
i think he would qualify as a serial
killer i think he had two three offenses
so
would target men in toilets cottaging
locations in london and you know bring
them back
get put them in a cubicle with a premise
of sexual contact and then strangle them
from behind
and again very very very psychopathic
because you've got to have that charm to
get people to do
what you want to do and some of the
other
you know some of the robbers i work with
like i said they just they don't have
the graft that you couldn't you wouldn't
you wouldn't trust this man as far as
you could throw them right so you'd
never be able to
trust them in a situation where you were
vulnerable there has to be a sort of
something disarming or uh seductive
about you so you need they need the
charm to offset the ick factor that
people feel when they're around them how
often is it how often does sex come into
this i was watching um
who was the dude that dressed up as the
clown in america
that clown killer
you know the one i mean come on people
are screaming it in today
i'm terrible i'm tired people terrible
i'm gonna i'm gonna google it um there's
this guy who was regularly killing
people he's one of the most famous
serial killers clown clown serial
killer john wayne gacy
johnny
right like i said i'm terrible
so
um one of the things that he it seemed
like he did was
he seemed to be sexually attracted
to
some or many or all of the boys that he
killed it was mostly guys that he killed
might have been exclusively guys that he
killed
but it seemed like he had a self-hatred
of his own sexuality it seemed like his
shame was one of the uh compulsions that
caused him to do that i'm just
interested by how much you know we've
talked about
some of these killers
going after sex workers
john wayne gacy here almost killing in
response perhaps to his own
uh sense of guilt or shame around his
sexuality how often does sex seem to
come into it
so
yeah that's an interesting question i
think
i guess i'm just hesitant to to say that
psychopaths have a particular
pattern of offending behavior because
they you know it really
the the range of offences we had in
somewhere like rampton was very very
broad and it included child sex offenses
but
um one of the interesting things about
rampton was that uh nobody in a hospital
you don't disclose people's offenses
so nobody
knew what anyone else had done so we had
this really interesting dynamic between
two old friends who were guys who were
in their 50s when i was there so you
know 20 years ago this they'd be quite
old now um and one of them was a child
sex offender and you know very sort of
overweight not not particularly
appealing person but his best mate was
someone called
tony or something and
tony was in the hospital because he
killed and dismembered a child sex
offender and it was really interesting
that these two had such a sort of
positive dynamic um that they uh
you know didn't know simply because they
didn't know each other's offenses um so
a real range of men in the same ward
with very very different offenses and i
i think the thing about
where there was that it seemed to be
that where there was a sexual element
uh psychopaths are quite sexually
promiscuous they don't kind of have
maybe the same scruples or strong
feelings about their what their partner
should be or look like that the rest of
us do they tend to be very promiscuous
but they also tend to target partners in
a way that would suggest like a sort of
marital type relationship so they don't
just sort of randomly go off and pull
people and you know
have sex with them and then leave them
they tend to try and pull people into a
more intimate relationship but only with
the goal of satisfying their needs for
comfort intimacy and perhaps also you
know things like money and
um
safety so you you know you live with
someone because they're your partner but
not because you're really interested in
ever having a long-term relationship
because they are meeting your
instrumental goals immediate
instrumental goals so this means that
sex becomes quite a sort of currency for
psychopaths which is something i would
say but the thing is then
the criminal justice system gets very
very black and white about what exactly
takes place in the index offense you
know and if you
someone can kill them it's likely that
the crown push prosecution service would
go for just the murder as the crime
rather than murder and rape because then
you've got two cases to build two
charges to consider two lots of evidence
you just go with the murder so some of
the crimes that people or that i would
have
understood and as being murder
might well have had sexual elements that
were not necessarily present in maybe
the description of the offense and that
could be kept secret because they were
never charged and convicted of you know
sexually intended murder an example was
when i worked within special hospitals
who murdered murdered a woman by
inserting a a sharpened um
a broom into her
into her vagina and it's just you know a
horrible way to go and he was
uh convicted of murder which meant that
he had protection from
all of being perceived as a i'm so sorry
being perceived as a sex offender or a
nonce or anything like that and he he
was also quite grandiose and quite
manipulative and he
used his status as a violent criminal a
murderer to avoid being targeted as a
sex offender and this is all about i
guess sort of the hierarchy of offences
and prisons of why people present
themselves in the way that they do um
but it was a little bit chilling that
you know this was clearly a sexual
offense but he got away without being
judged in that way because it's been
classified as a violent one by a sort of
slightly arbitrary system that's so
interesting the fact that because
what the criminal justice system is
actually looking for is is a conviction
and if you've got a conviction of murder
presumably that you're going to be in
there for so long that adding rape on
top of that is
is kind of
kind of pointless kind of doesn't really
make any sense so
yeah
it's also i every time that i speak to
somebody that works in prisons or with
criminals and stuff like that this
hierarchy of offense
um
always seems to come up and i suppose
that
beyond like your net worth in the the
prison has a little bit of a bearing on
you but not tons because you don't have
your money with you you know your
possessions or your house or the clothes
that you wear or the watch that you have
all of that stuff's been stripped away
from you your job title your
qualifications your education your
family you know all of this stuff really
doesn't really matter so one of the few
things you have that can quickly
identify where you sit in there is
what's on the rap sheet
ab absolutely and this leads to you know
these very bizarre hierarchies where
often as i said sex offenders are at the
bottom yep they are vulnerable prisoners
often we spend a lot of time and sort of
thought in the prison service protecting
them and at the top is you know the the
violent criminals um same murderers or
people who've committed attempted murder
which can be very misleading and at the
very top of that are the robbers because
the thing about robbing someone is this
pretty definitely you know
indisputably a violent offense and maybe
you did you know maybe you did or didn't
um kill someone i loved that uh in
prison break the the guy gets himself
into the prison by being a robber
because you just all you have to do to
rob them is threaten them with a weapon
right plausibly so you walk into a bank
with a gun make some sort of unspecified
threat you're a robber um and that
that goes a long way from sort of
somebody who is maybe a serial robber
who targets people very aggressively and
looking for an excuse to harm them to
someone who makes a sort of botched
attempt because they're a drug addict to
hold up a um a convenience store or
something and is busted and charged for
a very serious fence very very different
but but robbers the group of robbers
contains for example a lot of
psychopaths a lot of psychopaths has
anyone tried to cure psychopathy
yeah a lot of things have been tried
chris but um it's a pretty sad sad deal
there's
in the 60s and 70s they got quite
experimental they tried things like
naked encounter therapy they tried lsd
naked encounter therapy
so you take basically you take off all
your clothes and this was specifically
targeted for cycles you take all the
clothes sit around in a room together
talk about your life you're offending
and it there's sort of the
the idea i think behind it was that if
you strip off all the sort of social
expectations you'd find that at heart it
was so society that made psychopaths bad
and then you know you put them in a
primal situation they'd be much better
to each other but it it they weren't and
curiously enough it actually made them
worse or more likely to be convicted of
a violent offence after that so totally
total failure on every point isolation
tank therapy um and there were a few
there'd been a few like you know
well-meaning but misguided attempts to
use like less
uh
less directive form so ashworth hospital
had a uh personality disorder award
which had quite a few psychopaths on it
and the staff tried to be given a little
bit more freedom and i think the staff
somehow got the wrong end of the stick
about what freedom appropriate freedom
was for a psychopath and there was a one
of the patients who was there on a
transfer um
said that there was or accused or told
the hospital authorities that there was
a
girl being groomed by the the ward um
patients to come onto the ward and be
used for um
uh you know sex and other terrible
things and they lost the hospital
authorities and uh there was an inquiry
which found that basically the staff had
allowed themselves to be completely
manipulated out of the ward altogether
so there's also an interesting lesson
there about putting a lot of psychopaths
together in one place um which maybe we
hadn't learned by the time of dspd
who
is one of the scariest psychopaths that
you've worked with
so we i think thinking about um
uh
think about paul i mean he was sort of
scary in the sense of interpersonally
you know you wouldn't want to
to be with him
for any length of time because you you
know he might try and manipulate you and
he just might try and bully you and and
that that sort of constant sense of
threat uh the idea that there might be
other people on the wall everyone from
patients to prisoners to prison officers
might be working for him on some
capacity that's a very scary thought as
well you're never quite knowing who's on
your side but i think that
there are other characters who are
slightly more sinister than that
characters you really don't get to the
bottle and there was a patient i worked
within lower conditions of security but
who'd been up in
high security for a long time he was
someone who just seemed to be wired very
very differently
and the way that his wiring work was
that he was deeply unpredictable so you
could talk to him one day and you'd have
somebody who was quite pleasant and
engaged and interesting
and then it wasn't necessarily like hour
to hour but certainly day to day he
could switch into a very very aggressive
any questions what the [ __ ] are you
asking me that and you you still
thinking of the guy from yesterday so
you didn't know where this new guy came
from and his offending history was very
complex and there was a um
there was a murder in his history and
several other attacks on people and some
of it
may have had a sexual element but it was
again very difficult to tease out and if
somebody's not willing to work with you
to think about sort of the psychosexual
aspects of their offending you're never
going to get to the bottom of those
things and i think let's uh let's call
him trevor so trevor a the pleasant one
often dropped hints that he was ready to
talk about this stuff and then curiously
enough trevor b would shut up the next
day and tell you to [ __ ] off and that
would sort of be the end of the
discussion at least for the next year
until trevor appeared again but i think
that
this was a case that really affected me
and maybe i'm not describing it enough
but it that that inconsistency it used
to give me nightmares like i used to
have nightmares where either he was
killing me or i was killing him because
working as a clinician with someone like
that you get very very frustrated and
confused and difficult to organize your
thoughts because you don't know who's
going to be presenting your opposite so
i think that's sort of when somebody's
deeply unpredictable if someone is
predictably nasty that's actually okay
but it's like you know that's how trauma
works if if
the goal posts change every time you
come into work it can really mess you up
quite quickly and i think that i would
have said was that the case that
thinking of sort of generating a sense
of fear and anxiety i mean that
certainly did it the most yeah all right
mark let's bring this one home if people
want to check out the work that you do
where should they go
um i would say you know google me i've
got a university webpage and you can
also find my book making a psychopath
published by penguin in the uk and
macmillan and the usa it's a short read
it's it's not intended to be very
heavily academic or anything like that
and some of the characters i've talked
about today are in it as well so i hope
you enjoy it if you do happen to find it
all right mark i appreciate you lovely
to be here chris thanks so much for
having me what's happening people thank
you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace
you